Two years ago, we bought this land in Portugal,
and set up our Basekamp.
We installed a kitchen, and workspace in shipping containers...
Theworkspace is now all here...
Made a small garden...
Built a toilet...
Pizza Hut...
Set up solar energy...
Cleaned an old well...
And, set up a water system.
Water!
I'll show you on the map, what we did in Season1.
We made pathways, explored the land, discovered ruines,
water, and set up our infrastructure.
Now, we can live here.
But, our goal is to live here with many people...
So, this year we will test tosee,
if everything we made, actually works.
We will invite many strangers, from around the world,
and see what happens when we put them together.
In this video, you can see how that went,
and everything else we built this year.
Welcome to the Season 2 Recap of Project Kamp!
We start our journey at Basekamp, right here.
Thisis where we spend most of our time.
First thing, when people came, was getting installed.
Some cameby vans...
We actually have a big variety of them.
And, others had to set up their tents,
in a niceshaded area.
And some, found other places to sleep...
All right, so, time to start working, and wefigured:
"Let's build something fun and basic first."
We wanted a few wooden decks.
This was also agood test for us,
to try out how wood behaves in this climate.
Good to know for allour future structures we want to build.
So, we made three different decks,
with threedifferent types of wood, and coating.
So we can see how they behave over time...
Now, we have decks, where people can enjoy the view,
do yoga, or just relax.
And, so far, they work pretty well.
Let meshow you on the map, where they actually are.
We installed one on a big rock here...
One on the field, near the creek...
And a third one, near Basekamp.
And, this was a nice start!
Now, we'reready to jump into a bigger project,
what we were planning on, since we got theland.
Renovating our sketchy ruin, right here...
Last year, we cleaned it up,
because it was coveredwith spiky bushes...
It was a good discovery!
- Look at this! We never saw this side of house!
But, the buildingwas rough...
Burnt down, almost collapsing, and not straight at all.
Look at the building style of these bricks...
It's like an artwork.
This year, we started to renovate it,
and keep asmuch of the existing materials as possible.
Just so we have to use less new material...
Quite achallenge to reuse this.
We took down the roof....
Saved all the tiles...
Remove the bad wall...
Rebuild back, with the same bricks...
And now, we hadour not very straight base.
Look at the angles in these walls!
Now, the rough work was done,
andnext, we started to rebuild.
We installed a wooden frame, that will carry the weight of the roof,
because the brick wall itself is not very reliable...
Remain keeping that, to close the space,
and providesome insulation.
But, the bricks itself, they don't offer much support...
And, the whole structuregot even weaker,
when we made our last cut in the bricks, to make a big window in front.
Yeah, this was a bit sketchy, but hey...
- Look at the view!
Yeah, it's definitely not easier to reusethings...
But, luckily, everyone on YouTube thought it was a really good idea,
to keep the existingstructure.
Always nice to get some extra support.
Okay, so, let's leave this ruin for a bit.
We will finish this later...
Because, around this time, we were walking around,
in thisarea here on the land of the neighbors.
And, we heard the sound of water falling,
anddiscovered something hidden...
It was hard to see, but behind a lot of spiky bushes andthorns...
We found an awesome waterfall!
So, we started clearing it!
We found beautiful big old rocks stacked asa wall,
and discovered some sort of a gate...
We asked the neighbor, if it'sactually okay,
if we clean allof this.
And, he loved it!
He said it's been a while, since he came here.
He also said the gate was made for irrigation,
and that there was a big lagoon, behind the door.
We wanted to see that, and started cleaning up there.
Seems like a big open space...
And, after clearing it, it was much easier
to see the potential of thespace.
We could take a nice dip down here, but not yet on the top part...
Because, we found out thegate
was completely stuck, so there's no water...
And, we tried jacks and grinders, but it won't move...
So, we can't fill up the Lagoon yet...
You know I was quite disappointed...
It's frustrating, because wetried a lot of the instruments...
So, we decided for a more drastic approach.
Yep, we put ketchup on it!
No, that also didn't work...
We cut the thing in half, and took it out...
Brought it to the workspace...
Welded it back together...
Added some reinforcement...
Gave it a paint job...
And, put it back in.
Seems to work!
Now, we just have towait for rain to come,
at the end of the year...
So, while waiting, let's go back to theBasekamp,
where we made some upgrades.
In Season 1, we built this clay ovenand a pizza hut.
And this year, we integrated actually a good weekly routine.
Where we bakepizzas, and our sour-dough bread, every Friday.
But, doing this, we also realized the space
needed an upgrade, with a proper table.
So, with some old, not very straightwood,
we made a strong wooden frame.
And, we added a piece of granite on top.
Arock that you find a lot, in this region.
For painting the wood, we used the opportunity to trya natural ink.
Made from acorns, rust, and water we found on the land.
It created a deep black color, whichlooks pretty cool.
And, the table gives us a nice big surface to work with flour,
and doubles as anoffice during the week.
It's good to see our pizzas getting better!
From a first setup, with a shovel and a tarp,
to a proper structure, tools and table.
Another upgrade we needed, was the shower...
The onewe set up last year was temporary,
and made from bended branches laying around...
So, it was a bitexposed.
- Which means, there isn't much privacy...
Yeah, especially with more people around thisyear,
it became a bit of a thing...
So, we took it down, and built a new version,
with more straightplanks.
So, we don't have all the gaps in between...
And, for the water catchmentbasin, on the bottom...
- That's disgusting...
We tried making it with this new kind ofcement:
magnesium-phosphate.
Because, it's waterproof, and suited for the shower.
We want to explore alternative to the standard Portland cement,
since it'sa big carbon emitter in the world...
So, we did a bunch of tests to find the right ratio,
and mixture, and made a basin.
This was only a small little research,
but it's an interesting material though.
We will continue to see how it behaves in real life,
and let you know in the research module.
For now, we have a more private shower.
We also added a little bench outside...
And, installeda sink, from an old washer for the clothes.
Yeah, I don't know how you call thesethings, but it works.
- This works pretty well...
So, when summer came, we noticed a more
crucial thing popping up, to research.
Apparently, last year, Season1, for us was quite rainy...
This year is much drier, and hotter.
- It's hot!
Which, in this area, means forest fires, and lots of them.
On this app, you can see where they are...
Everywherearound us, and quite scary actually...
Especially, knowing that our own land burned down, five years ago.
This makes it very real, that it would likely happen again...
But, we realized, we don'tknow much about it,
or how to prevent it.
So, we went to visit a local fire department...
Ask the firefighters for tips...
We did an interview with a professor, focused on wildfires...
And, visiteda few big fires around.
We learned a lot, but the main take we got from it:
there's a lot ofwork ahead for us, to become more fire resilient.
Yeah, we needed to think moreabout this,
but in the summer, itwas just too hot...
Our creek driedup, which apparently rarely happens.
And, here you can see a green Basekampin the winter,
and a brown version in the summer.
It was really hard to work, and think, with the heat.
Yeah, I think Colleen sums it up pretty well here...
- No can do...
- We cannot do construction...
So, we took a swim at the local river,
to cool downfrom the heat.
And, made a planon what to do about these fires...
So, the land has many green areas around,
for itsvegetation to grow, and this is nice.
Well, sort of...
They can get really dry in summer, and becomea big fire!
It's basically a fuel for fire.
But, this all does depend on what kind of trees,
andbushes are actually growing there.
So, we started by mapping out all the trees,
that we have on the land.
Walking around on 10 hectares,
and identifying every native tree that we see growing.
Justto get an overview...
All the black dots are native trees.
We found a lot in this area!
And, we likethem a lot,
because they are more fire resilient.
And, the coolest one is a cork oak.
Thisone is most resilient, because they have a thick bark,
that protects them from fire.
Thisone actually burned out in the previous fire...
You still see the ash on my hand!
But, unlike all theother trees,
it survived, because of this thick bark.
But, they grow slow, so we're happy that
we still have a bunch of them on top of the rocks.
Anyway, next to Basekamp, almost everytree
is a mimosa, and they burn fast...
So, one of the main reasons to get ridof mimosas,
is to bring back the nativetrees.
But, also, to make the land abit more fire resilient...
Because, as you can see, they burn very fast...
And, this is a fresh cut of mimosa trees.
We asked some advice, from our neighborAntonio,
on what to do with all these trees.
Our neighbor's right.
Our Kamp is surrounded bypotential fire fuel.
So, we started to clean up that big mimosa patch,
behind the Basekamp.
Reducing potential fuel for fire.
We gathered the wood,
that couldbe used as firewood, for winter...
And, we use a wood chipper to chip thebranches.
We have a lot of mimosa on the land...
There's going to be an ongoing battle,
to live inharmony with them...
It's really impressive to see how fast they grow!
These trees started growingafter the last fire!
Look how big it got in five years!
Local people around us hate them for that.
It's just an annoying useless tree, like a weed...
But, we actually got curious to it!
There mustbe some use for it...
So, we wanted to see what we can actually make with it.
So, we did some woodcarving...
Took the bark, and used it to weave baskets...
Chopped some chunks,
to make stairs in ourbumpy terrain...
And, made a bar stool, to set at the new pizza table.
To make sure people can work happy.
Now that the stool is finished, Martijn can sit at the proper height,
with a straight back, and work happily!
Overall, the clearing was a big action,
but nothing compared to the size ofour entire land!
All of this is mimosa trees -- yikes!
So, this will be a long-term goal to worktowards...
Okay, for now, time to finish up the ruin!
We're going to close it up, and install the roof.
For that, we needed to get insulation material...
And, we love the heat resistant cork oak tree, yousaw before.
This is a great insulation material,
and actually grows a lot in Portugal.
They becomebig old trees, and every nine years, the bark is harvested,
and can be processed into insulationmaterial.
and the sounds of this harvesting were amazing
Silence, and the only thing you'llhear
is squeaky noises from the cork, and the axe.
And the cool thing, is that the tree staysalive, when harvested.
This cork gets shredded, and processed.
And, what makes expanded corkeven cooler, is that it's all natural,
and no glue is needed, to make these panels.
Just heat, andpressure, that binds it together.
Pretty cool!
So, we got some for the ruin,
and started to put it on theroof.
We put the cork on the wooden beams...
Added the waterproof layer...
And, added thoseold reused tiles, from before, on top.
Now, it's waterproof!
Next: the interior!
We installed some oldwindows, that we got
from a local guy, that had them left-over.
We placed the wooden frame on the walls...
And, insulated the whole thing with our beloved cork.
Next, we finished the walls with wood panels...
And, used the same panels to make the floor.
Finally, we added some recycled plastic sockets,
madewith Precious Plastic machines...
And, used old-schoollight switches.
And, when it was all done, we addedthe stove,
so we could heat it up in the winter.
This will be a big upgrade,
comparedto the steamy van, last year.
And finally, we also built a verandaoutside.
This is so we can enter the house easily,
but also have a niceplace to sit, and enjoy the view.
Here we have a nice view,to Antonio's and Fernanda's house.
We actually invited to her,
so shecould have a look in the house.
She used to live in this beautiful,
orange brick, when she was younger.
Good to hear she likes it!
Talking about neighbors, around the end of the year,
they often ask us for some help with harvesting.
Things like potatoes...
This is a big job for them, as they're getting older,
but we have lots of energy!
And, it's fun!
At the end, we always get a littlehomemade snack.
There are also a few other projects around in the region,
where we source some of ourveggies.
We like to visit, and help, if needed.
In these years, we realized it's very useful to have
a regional network, and learn from each other's experiences.
- Thank you!
- Well, if you'rehappy, I'm happy!
Okay, so, back to the map!
We still have some stuff to show you,
our neighborsactually told us about.
They often mentioned some things, from the old days,
that used to be onthe land...
And, one of them was an old building somewhere here,
between these bushes, and it'shard to see.
So, we cleaned it up, to get a better look.
And, we found this very old collapsedruin...
It requires some imagination to see it...
- A piece of metal that turned the door...
I'm not sure yet what to do with it, but...
Good to know there's a pile of stones here.
And, we made a technical drawing of it,
but no future plans yet.
So, the ruin was there, and another thing theymentioned,
is that we have a well, on the bottomof our land, around here.
And, we searchedbefore, but we never found it...
And, they keep telling us it should be in this area.
So, after somesearching, we finally found it,
under a pile of wood...
- Hey! Over here!
And, we figured: let's clean it up,
before the rain comes, so it can fill up.
And, jobs like this can go really fast, with many hands!
Wecleared the area around it,
and emptied the dirt that was inside.
Looks like a pretty cool oldwell,
which I guess will be useful in the future.
So, at this point, the dry summer is over,
andthe winter is starting...
Which means: rain, lots of it...
Really good to see the plants coming back tolife,
and the creek flowing again.
And, the new well is filling up with water...
- Feels like a goodstart!
So, this also means we can test the door from the waterfall!
We can close it up, to see whathappens.
It's really good seeing the lagoon fill up!
It stores a lot of water, as you can see.
But, you really notice this,
when youopen it up, and it all comes out.
Yeah, this action actually flushed away our GoPro,
now it's...
- Somewhere are there but there are a lot of brumbles...
And, we thought THIS was a lot of water!
But, after a few months of rain, the waterfall was on steroids!
Instead of a waterfall, it becamemore like 20 waterfalls!
Such a cool place...
So, that was it -- everything we made so far!
Now, Season 3 is starting,
with a new video coming every monday!
Subscribe on Youtube, to follow our journey...
And, support us on Patreon,
to see videos one week ahead!
Thanks to everyone watching this!
Project Kamp would not be possible without you!